[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement avec vos quartiers Gilders oui
Alexandre et notre invité cette semaine
et Laurent jacobelli bonjour vous êtes
député rassemblement national de Moselle
votre circonscription et celle qui
englobe notamment les villes bien
connues d'ailleurs et de Florence et on
va revoir avec vous le film très riche
de la semaine et les députés des bas de
cette semaine de la lutte contre les
squatteurs une proposition de loi de la
majorité visa durcir les sanctions
contre l'occupation illicite de
logements les sénateurs poursuivent
l'examen du budget à la majorité de
droite du Sénat approuve la hausse des
moyens des forces de l'ordre de la
justice mais rejettent le budget dédié à
l'immigration les députés à ce moment
national lance une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur l'ingérence des pays
étrangers dans les partis politiques
français mais d'abord une question
d'actualité sur la réforme des retraites
puisque ce vendredi dans Le Parisien la
première ministre Elisabeth borne a
dévoilé les premières mesures de la
réforme des retraites il y aura bien un
recul progressif de l'âge de départ à
65 ans d'ici à 2031 une retraite
minimale à 1200 euros et la fin des
régimes spéciaux Laurent jacobelli à la
première vue est-ce que les députés RN
sont toujours opposés à cette réforme
oui totalement et complètement moi je
suis choqué par cette déclaration chez
vos confrères du Parisien sur le fond et
sur la forme d'abord sur la forme c'est
quand même étonnant lorsqu'on est
parlementaire de connaître les grandes
lignes du projet de la réforme des
retraites en lisant la presse mais ça
montre bien que ce gouvernement boude le
Parlement ne veut pas travailler avec le
Parlement et refuse de travailler
notamment avec les députés pourquoi
parce qu'il n'a pas la majorité absolue
ce gouvernement est entêté obtu il
déteste les contre-propositions il
déteste l'opposition maintenant sur le
fond moi je me demande si Madame borne
s'est fait greffer une calculette à la
place du coeur le modèle social des
retraites français c'est un modèle
solidaire un modèle fraternel elle veut
en faire un modèle économiquement
performant mais si c'est le cas si c'est
le cas elle doit savoir que aujourd'hui
au moment où on se parle
c'est sur deux arrive à la retraite en
étant soit au chômage soit en invalidité
décaler l'âge de la retraite dans le
temps ce sera décalé d'autant le nombre
de subventions chômage le nombre de mois
au RSA ou le nombre de mois en pension
d'invalidité donc tout cela n'a aucun
sens ni socialement ni économiquement
mais selon vous comment on fait pour
rééquilibrer ce régime des retraites qui
sera déficitaire en 2027 à plus de 12
milliards d'euros quel est votre
proposition alors déjà je ne remets pas
en cause vos sources mais on nous fait
le coup à chaque fois et on s'est aperçu
cette année on le voit pour l'année
prochaine que les caisses sont plus
pleines qu'on nous l'avait annoncé le
Comité d'Orientation des Retraites nous
dit que vers le milieu des années 2030
nous serons à l'équilibre pour des
raisons purement démographiques donc
pour quelques années difficiles c'est
vrai vous avez raison probablement fin
des années 2020 début des années 2030 on
va casser un modèle social je vais vous
dire c'est l'inverse qu'il faut faire
c'est dire quand vous avez commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans vous aurez la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités si
vous avez travaillé commencé à
travailler après 20 ce sera jusqu'à 62
ans 42 années d’animité c'est finançable
c'est donc du bon sens en disant que il
y aura un défi en promettant qui aura un
déficit abyssal c'est rien n'est fait
pour vous ce n'est pas vrai bah c'est
faux en tout cas au mieux si jamais il y
a une once de vérité dans la parole de
Madame borne et du gouvernement on va
effectivement renflouer un peu les
caisses de retraite mais aggraver les
caisses chômage et les caisses sécurité
sociale parce que je le répète
aujourd'hui les Français ne partent pas
à la retraite en ayant un emploi pour un
sur deux donc le vrai problème c'est
l'emploi des seniors le vrai problème
c'est de l'emploi parce que plus il y
aura d'emplois plus il y aura de
cotisations je rappelle qu'il y a
aujourd'hui plus de 5 millions de
chômeurs en France est-ce que vous
appelez les Français à descendre dans la
rue contre cette réforme de retraite je
sais pas ils feront ce qu'ils veulent
moi je n'ai pas ni à les inciter ni à
les empêcher je leur dis simplement que
il faut qu'il sache que ce gouvernement
n'est pas là pour les aider que ce
gouvernement n'obéit pas
aux Français il obéit à Bruxelles voilà
parce que pourquoi on fait cette réforme
des retraites disons-le le plan de
relance fin par Bruxelles pour sortir de
la crise que nous traversons à une
clause et dans cette clause il est
imposé à la France de faire une réforme
des retraites pour être simple quand on
donne 100 euros à l'Union européenne
elle nous rend 65 et en même temps elle
met des conditions pour nous rendre ses
65 donc les frères les Français perdent
leur argent et perdent leur système de
retraite c'est perdant perdant alors on
change alors on va passer à au film
parlementaire de la semaine l'assemblée
s'est penchée cette semaine sur la
question des squatteurs une proposition
de loi pour durcir les sanctions et les
expulsions en cas d'occupation illicite
de logement était alors du jour en
séance publique bronca sur les rangs de
gauche contre ce texte résumé de séance
avec Stéphanie Despierres
défendre les propriétaires dont les
maisons sont squatées c'est l'objectif
de Guillaume kasbarian le député
Renaissance veut tripler les sanctions
encourues par les squatteurs en les
passant à 3 ans d'emprisonnement et 45
000 euros d'amende il se heurte à une
levée de boucliers de la gauche en
lisant certains amendements des groupes
LFI et écologistes j'ai l'impression que
certains veulent défendre les squats
allonger les procédures ou simplement ne
veulent pas parler de ces petits
propriétaires en difficulté au simple
motifs qu'ils sont propriétaires celles
et ceux d'entre vous qui ont reçu un
jour dans leur permanence un citoyen
dans le domicile esquatté ou un
propriétaire dont le bien est occupé par
un locataire qui ne paye plus depuis des
années savent que la situation actuelle
ne peut plus durer nous avons le devoir
d'agir c'est ce qu'attendent les
victimes Guillaume casbariant propose
aussi de réduire les délais d'expulsion
en cas d'impayés la nuit Pesse estime
que le texte amalgame les squatteurs
avec les locataires qui ont du mal à
payer leur loyer on essaye de médiatiser
des situations qui sont gravissime
scandaleuse mais exceptionnelle qui est
celui de la violation de domicile pour
lequel tout l'arsenal juridique existe
pour finalement durcir la législation
pour accélérer les expulsions locatives
des gens qui sont difficultés de
paiement c'est ça la réalité de cette
loi c'est pas la lutte contre les squats
les républicains et le rassemblement
national soutiennent la proposition de
renaissance et le RN en profite pour
fustiger la politique du logement de la
gauche lorsqu'elle était au pouvoir vous
opposez les honnêtes gens qui paye votre
faillite sur le logement aux années de
gens qui ont investi dans un logement et
qui sont victimes du laxisme judiciaire
tout ce qui permet de défendre les
petits propriétaires nous le voterons le
texte prévoit aussi d'inclure
systématiquement dans le bail une clause
de résiliation de plein droit pour
accélérer l'expulsion en cas de loyer
impayés
alors la dernière loi qui régit les
expulsions de logement date de 2020
selon vous qu'apporte cette nouvelle
proposition de loi est-ce que c'est un
texte fait sous la pression des des
médias et des affaires médiatiques
récentes non je ne crois pas en tout cas
je ne le pense pas le texte de 2020 a
bien montré son inefficacité c'était
finalement un brouillon de ce qui nous
est proposé aujourd'hui le gouvernement
s'est rendu compte que ce qu'il avait
fait voter ne fonctionnait pas oui il y
a encore aujourd'hui des gens qui ont
peur de partir en vacances parce qu'ils
ne veulent pas au retour trouver
chez eux une famille qui a squatté oui
il y a des gens qui refusent aujourd'hui
d'investir pour louer parce qu'il pense
que c'est trop risqué donc pour relancer
le logement il faut oui une loi
anti-squateur et puis finalement ce pays
marche un peu sur la tête aujourd'hui le
squatteur est plus défendu que le
propriétaire aujourd'hui au moment où on
se parle un propriétaire qui veut
récupérer son bien finalement risque
trois fois plus de peine que le
squatteur il faut rééquilibrer tout ça
mais vous savez il manque quand même un
volant important dans cette dans ce
projet de loi
comment on fait appliquer la loi c'est
le volet opérationnel le problème c'est
qu'il n'est pas inscrit dans cette loi
comment le préfet est obligé de mettre
en place les moyens pour déloger les
squatteurs et puis honnêtement cette
gauche aujourd'hui cette gauche qui a eu
ces ordres de gloire dans le social est
devenu une gauche indigne la gauche qui
défend les voleurs par rapport aux
années de gens la gauche qui défend
systématiquement ceux qui violent la
propriété par rapport aux petits
épargnants on a une gauche une gauche
déboussolée qui aujourd'hui défend les
voyous et accuse les victimes non les
petits propriétaires ne sont pas des
profiteurs et non les squatteurs ne sont
pas des pauvres gens ce sont des
délinquants mais justement ce que vous
appelez squatteur voleur voyou est-ce
que ce ne sont pas avant tout des
personnes qui sont victimes du mal
logement est-ce que vous ne défendez pas
les propriétaires contre les mal logés
vous savez je suis choqué par cet
argument choqué par le fait qu'on puisse
penser que des gens qui sont mal logés
qui sont en situation difficile donc
comme seul objectif que de violer la loi
et
que squatter la propriété d'autrui non
beaucoup de Français vivent dans une
situation difficile c'est vrai mais pour
autant ils sont honnêtes moi j'ai du mal
avec cette excuse que trouve la gauche
en disant bah oui mais les gens qui ont
des difficultés sont amenés à voler ou à
ce côté non 99 % des gens qui sont en
difficulté sont des gens honnêtes et
j'en connais beaucoup dans ma
circonscription juste un mot quand même
parce qu'il y a effectivement un
problème de logement dans notre pays il
serait temps de mettre en place la
priorité nationale que les Français et
la priorité sur le logement social
aujourd'hui on le voit bien il y a une
sur-représentation des familles
étrangères dans l'occupation des
habitations à loyer modérés ce n'est
plus tenable les Français qui
travaillent les Français qui ont une vie
digne qui respecte la loi doivent avoir
la priorité sur le logement ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui on peut même voir que
dans le placement dans les logements
sociaux aujourd'hui il y a une forme de
préférence étrangère une urgence
migrants et bien moi je pense qu'il y a
plutôt une urgence française alors il y
avait deux propositions de loi déposées
sur un autre sujet par nos collègues les
républicains pour faciliter l'expulsion
des étrangers d'élinquants elles ont été
rejetées par l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous le regrettez ce que vous
allez
vous attendez peut-être que ces
dispositions figurent dans la prochaine
le prochain texte proposé par Gérald
darmanination alors je vais pas vous
étonner en vous disant que je n'attends
rien de Gérald Darmanin l'homme qui a
été incapable d'arrêter l'imamicusen
l'homme qui a laissé 230 migrants
arrivés sur le shonviking et les a perdu
dans la nature l'homme qui a fait tomber
le taux des auqtf obligation de quitter
le territoire français appliqué en
dessous de 10% ne règlera pas ni le
problème de la sécurité ni le problème
de l'immigration ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine à l'Assemblée nationale
sur cette proposition de loi des
républicains et terrifiants la nupes
l'extrême gauche radical nous a dit que
même s'il était un terroriste même s'il
était un criminel un migrant devait
rester en France quoi qu'il en coûte sur
la sécurité de nos concitoyens vous me
direz c'est ce qu'on attend de l'extrême
gauche mais le gouvernement lui a
emboîté le pas c'est à dire que le
gouvernement pour c'est le texte dès les
premières minutes à voter cette
proposition de la nupesse qui a été de
casser la proposition de loi des
républicains et le gouverne il y a un
accord de fête il y a eu un accord de
fête ce gouvernement n'accepte pas que
les oppositions puissent faire des
propositions et puissent gagner une
bataille au sein du Parlement alors tous
les moyens sont bons le carence 9,3 le
dépôt de sous amendement fantaisiste et
même l'alliance avec l'extrême gauche
radicale qui défendra toujours les
migrants même criminels par rapport aux
Français victime je crois qu'on a
franchi un pas de plus dans la naissance
et pourtant le gouvernement et Charles
Le Darmanin sont favorables à ce
principe de la double peine pour les
étrangers délinquants un principe qu'ils
veulent introduire dans le futur projet
loi immigration donc ce texte ira dans
le bon sens selon vous mais une fois
encore comment les croire aujourd'hui on
a Monsieur Darmanin qui fait le tour des
plateaux de télévision qui montre les
muscles mais de fait au premier semestre
au premier trimestre je ne sais plus
2021 le taux des auqtf était à 5,6%
historiquement bas il a accueilli le
jeune Vik alors que plus personne ne
veut de ce type de bateau qui sont des
bateaux taxis des voies express de
migrants vers l'Europe bref ce
gouvernement a tous les records en
matière d'immigration légale et légales
tous les records en matière de l'axisme
mais il vient nous dire qu'il va régler
le problème non pour régler le problème
on a une solution simple il faut fournir
un projet de loi Clément aux Français et
leur demander leur avis par référendum
c'est la condition pour laquelle vous
accepteriez de voter ce projet de loi
mais d'abord il va falloir et d'abord il
va falloir le lire mais je vous le dis
quand les premières mesures en février
au Sénat en mars à l'Assemblée
octobre puis novembre puis février mars
on verra bien on voit bien qu'ils sont
gênés aux alentours murs parce que la
seule mesure concrète qu'on a pour
l'instant c'est la régularisation des
sans-papiers qui travaillent donc
excusez-moi en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration on a fait mieux justement
vous parliez de l'ochène Viking le
député rassemblement national Grégoire
de Fournas est revenu à l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine après deux
semaines d'exclusion pour avoir crié je
cite qu'il retourne en Afrique au moment
où un député noir de LFI s'exprimer à
propos de ce bateau de migrants aux
chêne Viking après cet épisode on a
l'impression Laurent jacobelli que
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale est
devenu une foire d'emploine ou les
invectives des insultes fusent est-ce
que c'est digne des lieux de la
République d'abord je ne ferai pas la
malgave entre ce qu'a dit le député
Grégoire de Fournas et le fait que
l'assemblée soit devenu un ring de boxe
c'était déjà le cas avant et il a été
victime de cela ils n'ont pas coupable
répétons le il a dit que les bateaux qui
arrivaient d'Afrique pour amener des
migrants clandestins en France devait
retourner dans leur pays d'origine c'est
ce que je crois pense une majorité de
Français en tout cas c'est ce que nous
pensons aussi la manière de l'exprimer a
été on va dire énergie qu'elle était
dans la chaleur de l'hémicycle mais elle
a été exploitée par la nupes et le
gouvernement la majorité se sont
engouffrés dans la brèche en disant ça
fera toujours un peu de buzz oui
effectivement je le regrette en tant que
député l'assemblée est souvent le lieu
de combat non pas idéologique n'ont pas
politique n'ont pas de proposition mais
des joutes qui sont plutôt des buzz que
des joues de verbales c'est la France
insoumise qui a importé le cirque et la
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale pour
eux on est comme à une AG à Nanterre
avant une grève générale je crois qu'il
va falloir leur expliquer quelle
règlement d'ailleurs il va falloir faire
appliquer le règlement et pas seulement
à l'encontre des députés du
rassemblement national mais pour tous
les députés il y a un deux poids de
mesure à l'Assemblée nationale qui
commence à devenir inquiétant et la
majorité joue un peu à ce petit jeu
aussi allez on avance direction le Sénat
ou l'examen du budget 2023 se poursuit
la majorité des droites du Sénat a
approuvé une hausse des moyens de la
police de la justice mais à rejeter une
augmentation des crédits dédiés à
l'immigration Samia des chiens pas de
désaccord majeurs sur les budgets
régaliens cette semaine le Sénat a voté
à une large majorité une hausse des
crédits sécurité de 1,25 milliards
d'euros proposé par le gouvernement pour
l'année 2023 elle doit permettre de
financer la modernisation numérique des
forces de l'ordre et de renouveler leur
équipement
la majorité sénatorielle a également
approuvé une hausse de 8% du budget du
ministère de la Justice
710 millions d'euros supplémentaires
seront débloqués en 2023 pour permettre
des recrutements dans les tribunaux et
la création de place de prison service
public de la justice volerait ainsi les
10 milliards d'euros pour l'année 2023
d'aucun diront peut-être que ceci n'est
jamais assez mais je veux dire que
c'est plus que cela n'a jamais été les
sénateurs ont en revanche rejeté le
budget asile et immigration le
gouvernement prévoyait une augmentation
de près de 6% l'an prochain pas assez
pour la gauche et bien trop pour la
droite qui dénonce des dépenses
incontrôlables et une politique
d'immigration trop floue un budget c'est
la traduction d'une politique
l'abondement d'un budget n'est pas une
politique avant nous une politique
migratoire légale et illégales sur ce
territoire je ne le crois pas nous
traitons les problèmes au fil de l'eau
il va falloir définir une politique
c'est ce que nous ferons je l'espère la
droite sénatoriale a donc logiquement
rejeté également une augmentation du
budget de l'aide médicale d'État aux
étrangers en situation irrégulière le
gouvernement prévoyait une augmentation
de 133 millions d'euros le Sénat a
préféré voter une baisse de 350 millions
d'euros et à restreint le périmètre de
cette aide au seul soin d'urgence par
l'éventail des soins couverts la me
constitue par rapport au pays voisins
une exception difficile à justifier dans
la plupart d'entre eux seuls les soins
urgents les soins liés à la maternité
les soins aux mineurs et les dispositifs
de soins préventifs dans les programmes
sanitaires publics sont prises en charge
gratuitement pour les étrangers en
situation irrégulière une restriction de
l'aide médicale d'État votée contre la
vie du gouvernement et des groupes de
gauche les désaccords pourront être
tranchés par une commission mixte
paritaire entre députés et sénateurs ou
par un nouveau recours du gouvernement
au 49-3 pour une adoption sans vote à
l'Assemblée nationale
nos voix donc Laurent jacobelli la
majorité de droite du Sénat donc rejeté
le budget dédié à l'asile et à
l'immigration en hausse de 6% pour l'an
prochain les sénateurs de la
républicains ont bien fait oui sûrement
bien sûr il faut même aller plus loin
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui l'aide
médicale d'État c'est à dire pour parler
clair
open bar à l'hôpital pour tous les
migrants même clandestins donc il faut
la supprimer voilà il faut réduire à 300
et une enveloppe globale de 300 millions
d'euros une forme de dispensaire
d'urgence bien sûr on va pas laisser
quelqu'un mourir bien sûr on va pas
laisser quelqu'un propager des maladies
mais il faut une politique raisonnable
parce que c'est devenu une véritable
haute aspirante pompe aspirante les gens
du monde entier savent que même s'ils
arrivent illégalement en France il se
feront soigner gratuitement et à peu
près tout la dentition les yeux etc et
donc c'est un appel terrifiant mais
on est sans illusion ce budget va faire
l'objet d'un 49-3 c'est une évidence
mais ce budget il est mal tricoté on
voit bien aujourd'hui que ce qui manque
c'est effectivement de l'argent pour la
police et la justice mais c'est surtout
une volonté lorsque des policiers
arrêtent chaque jour des gens qui sont
libérés par des juges qui leur trouve en
permanence des excuses c'est quelque
chose qui dysfonctionne tant qu'on aura
monsieur Dupont-Moretti au ministère de
la Justice vous pouvez injecter des
milliards alors rien ne changera 1,5
milliards d'euros pour vous c'est pas
suffisant c'est bien mais c'est quand
même que le gouvernement fait un effort
c'est très bien sauf qu'il faut surtout
appliquer les peines
faites comme moi je les fais récemment
une patrouille de la justice oui mais
faites une patrouille avec les gendarmes
et il vous diront quand vous patrouillez
avec eux ah bah lui c'est un trafiquant
de drogue lui il a agressé sa femme il
le savent et bien ils vont une nouvelle
fois les arrêter et ils seront une
nouvelle fois libéré et c'est pas
seulement parce que les tribunaux sont
engorgés c'est vrai c'est le cas mais
c'est aussi parce qu'il y a une logique
de l'excuse une logique de la repentance
générale qui fait que les voyous sont
victimisés et que les victimes sont
ignorées et donc il faut de fonte en
comble revoir notre système de sécurité
et de justice et des nos policiers
arrêtés de les critiquer moi j'en ai un
peu ras-le-bol d'entendre sur les bancs
de l'Assemblée que la police tue que la
police serait une forme de nouvelle
criminalité vous entendez ce genre ah
bah là
la gauche nupes passe son temps à nous
expliquer que les voyous sont des
victimes de la société et que la police
sont le bras armé d'une bourgeoisie
vindicative ces gens-là sont dans un
schéma d'un autre siècle ils n'ont à
rien compris mais on voit bien pourquoi
ils le font ils le font pas
électoralisme ils vise une forme de
communautarisme qui est leur électorat
et il faut le dire il nie une évidence
c'est le lien entre immigration et
insécurité un mot sur la forme l'examen
de ce texte budgétaire le Sénat va voter
la semaine prochaine sur l'ensemble de
ce budget après deux semaines d'examen
après l'avoir modifié en profondeur
alors qu'à l'Assemblée nation au final
vous avez pas eu vraiment la possibilité
de modifier ce texte une succession de
recours à l'article 49-3 finalement ce
passage en force du gouvernement il
s'est un peu banalisé au fil de la
semaine oui le passage en force du
gouvernement est devenu une méthode de
gestion Jupiter n'a pas accepté qu'il y
ait une contradiction dans son propre
pays il n'a pas accepté le verdict des
urnes aujourd'hui le gouvernement est
sous tutelle sous tutelle des
oppositions qui sont là pour contreroler
observer rediriger l'action du
gouvernement et ça il ne l'accepte pas
Jupiter est devenu Narcisse il en a fait
une question d'ego personnelle et donc
le président de la République veut
imposer ses vues et Madame borne est
finalement son agent exécutant elle
vient une fois par semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale elle nous explique que notre
travail est acheté à la poubelle que nos
électeurs n'ont aucune voie au chapitre
et qu'ils feront exactement ce qu'ils
veulent cette morgue se mépris du
Parlement constitutionnel pour ce qui
est du 49-3 a laissé la place aussi à
des méthodes un peu moins no le dépôt de
sous amendement en masse pour faire
capoter un projet de loi de l'opposition
une proposition de l'opposition des
alliances contre nature avec l'extrême
gauche radicale pour empêcher des lois
qui vont vers plus de sécurité plus de
contrôle de l'immigration bref ce
gouvernement est à la dérive il ne sait
plus où il habite une dissolution ou pas
en tout cas la menace est brandi elle
deviendra réalité que les républicains
parce que le parti les républicains et
celui qui pourrait être le plus
victime de cette dissolution et qui donc
parfois est amené à faire le dos rond
par rapport aux demandes du gouvernement
en tout cas moi nous fait pas peur je
vous le dis elle nous fait pas peur du
tout d'abord on est prêt et deuxièmement
je suis assez persuadé qu'on doublera au
minimum le nombre de députés donc s'il
veut jouer à ça le président de la
République et qui veut faire du chantage
ça nous inquiète pas vous savez les
menaces de 49-3 les menaces de
dissolution ne nous font pas peur nous
ne courberons pas les Chine on est là
pour défendre les Français et on le fera
quoi que veille faire le gouvernement
Laurent Jacoby on passe au dernier thème
de cette émission mercredi les députés
ont validé la commission la d'une
commission d'enquête sur les réseaux
d'influence étrangères et le financement
des partis politiques c'était une
demande du rassemblement nationale
plusieurs groupes se sont abstenus
invoquant les contours vagues de cette
commission écoutez la réaction de ce
député
Erwan
çant presque une gêne de tous les
groupes sur cette question parce que
c'est un droit de tirage et que c'est
important qu'on nous ayons ce droit de
tirage cette c'est dans notre règlement
et ça participe du très bon
fonctionnement de de notre rôle de
contrôle
enfin une fois qu'on a dit ça je pense
que quand on quand on lit et il a été
fait par Madame winter Mayer libellé on
voit que quelque part c'est du travail
un peu
je vais pas dire d'amateur parce que
c'est pas sympathique avec de votre part
et je pense que vous ne l'êtes pas mais
il y a quand même quelques critères
juridiques et qui ne sont pas vraiment
maîtrisés alors est-ce qu'une commission
d'enquête a pour but de servir les
intérêts d'un parti pour laver l'honneur
du parti comme l'a dit Jean-Philippe
Tanguy en présentant la demande de
commission d'enquête mais c'est pas
l'intérêt d'un parti c'est l'intérêt
national nous avons été victimes d'un
certain nombre d'accusations
diffamatoires sur des liens supposés
disons-le avec la Russie or nous nous
savons que ces liens sont fantasmés par
une opposition qui n'a pas une majorité
pardon qui n'a pas grand chose à nous
opposer puisque les Français sont
d'accord avec nous alors chiche disons
la vérité en français faisons une
enquête plutôt que les ragots opposant
les faits et je vois bien la gêne
d'autres groupes parce que certains
n'ont pas tellement envie qu'on creuse
le lien avec le Qatar avec la Chine avec
d'autres puissances et bien on verra
bien ce qu'il en ressort en tout cas
nous on est très serein contrairement à
je vois des parties de la majorité même
certains partis d'opposition qui
commence à trembler à l'idée qu'on
puisse aller fouiner dans leur
financement et leurs liens avec des
parties et des pays étrangers et bien
très bien les Français méritent la
vérité non jacobelli on se souvient du
débat d'entre eux autour de la dernière
présidentielle ou Emmanuel Macron avait
dit à Marine Le Pen vous parlez de votre
banquier quand vous parlez de Monsieur
Poutine en référence à un prêt de 2014
souscrit par le Front national à une
banque russe alors aujourd'hui cette
banque russe a fait faillite est-ce que
vous confirmez que cette créance elle
existe toujours auprès d'un groupe super
aéronautique russe cette créance existe
toujours pour être précis quand même
parce que je veux pas laisser la place à
des à des fantasmes une fois encore
aucune banque française aucune banque
européenne n'a accepté pour des
élections pour prêter à Marine Le Pen et
au rassemblement national premier parti
d'opposition de français déjà un déni
démocratique on a trouvé une banque
tchécos russe qui a accepté de nous
prêter de l'argent sous contrôle de la
commission
CNCCFP qui est la commission qui
contrôle les comptes des partis
politiques de façon transparente sous
contrôle d'une banque française parce
que c'est la loi donc de manière
totalement transparente tous les flux
financiers ont été contrôlés cette
banque a fait faillite qui montre bien
d'ailleurs qu'elle n'était pas dans les
mains du gouvernement russe sinon
probablement qu'elle n'aurait pas fait
faillite elle nous a fait un taux de 6%
qui est pas un taux d'amis croyez moi
qui est plus près de l'usure que du taux
d'amis et cette banque a fait faillite
et donc les créances ont été rachetées
par un groupe industriel nous avons un
plan de remboursement nous remboursons
nos dettes tout cela est vérifié par les
autorités françaises vous savez s'il y
avait la moindre mal s'il y avait le
moindre mouvement financier suspect
comme nous sommes le rassemblement
national nous aurions été déjà rattrapés
par la patrouille tout est extrêmement
clair mais alors à ce moment là que le
Président de la République soit cohérent
qu'il mette en place la banque de la
démocratie qu'il avait promise
c'est-à-dire une banque qui fait des
prêts aux candidats lorsqu'il y a des
élections et le président de la
République qui semble si
pointilleux sur les comptes de campagne
je suis sûr verra d'une d'un bon œil
enquête sur mckinzey l'enquête qui
devrait avoir lieu sur ces liens avec
Hubert que MSC Croisières n'a aucun lien
avec le gouvernement ou des membres du
Cabinet du Président de la République je
pense que il faut balayer devant sa
porte avant d'accuser les autres allez
on va terminer en jetant un coup d’œil à
l'agenda de la semaine prochaine au
Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lundi en séance publique à l'Assemblée
nationale début de l'examen du projet de
loi du ENR sont notre code énergie
renouvelable qui a déjà été votée au
Sénat deux semaines d'examen prévu dans
l'hémicycle et mardi 6 décembre après
les questions d'actualité place au débat
sur l'immigration et puis mardi au Sénat
ce sera le vote final sur le budget 2023
mercredi l'examen d'une proposition de
loi sur la hausse des prix de l'énergie
et sur l'accompagnement des
collectivités territoriales et puis
jeudi un autre texte pour créer une
délégation parlementaire au droit de
l'enfant c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup
et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi et on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine ciao
ciao
[Musique]